would you play Call of Duty if it was on
switch because Microsoft has announced a
10-year commitment that will see the
franchise published on Nintendo
platforms again if the pending
acquisition of Activision Blizzard is
approved the deal was announced in a
tweet by Phil Spencer who added that
Call of Duty will also continue to be
offered for PC players on Steam
simultaneously with Xbox Spencer's tweet
is a light on details though the Xbox
lead elaborated on some details in an
interview with the Washington Post
saying that the entire Call of Duty
portfolio will be evaluated for a
potential switch release he suggested
that it could be sometime before we will
see the First Call of Duty title on
switch though with development only able
to start after the merger deal is closed
which is scheduled for June 23rd If
approved by Regulators when asked if it
would be difficult to Port the Call of
Duty titles for the switch Spencer
pointed to Microsoft's experience with
shipping Minecraft on the handheld
console as proof of the company's
ability to quote run a development team
that is targeting multiple platforms
meanwhile Sony has raised the potential
of Call of Duty becoming exclusive as a
reason why the merger shouldn't be
approved however the company reportedly
has not accepted a deal that would keep
Call of Duty on PlayStation for 10 years
just imagine a world where Call of Duty
is on switch but not on PlayStation
scary isn't it and you know what else is
scary fighting people in Elden Rings
coliseums the game's big update launches
today December 7th and thanks to a full
list of patch notes we now know what
else it includes there are multiple new
hairstyles for players General balance
tweaks and a series of bug fixes let's
start with the coliseums the one in Lim
grave has two modes United combat a
team-based mode where the team with the
most kills at the end of the timer wins
and combat ordeal a free-for-all mode
with respawns with a person with the
most kills at the end wins the Kayla
Coliseum has one mode dual a 1v1 fight
with no respawns the layondel Coliseum
has all three modes mentioned and it's
important to note that all of them allow
for Spirit Ashes to be summoned during
combat when it comes to the new
hairstyles formsoft didn't say much but
you can see them in the character editor
as for the balance changes daggers axes
and hammers have had their recovery time
reduced while there are numerous
reductions to speed and damage of
various other weapons and game elements
as for bug fixes players won't have to
deal with various issues that prevented
spell incantation and item input actions
from working in some scenarios the
update also fixes a bug that could cause
consumable items to fail to replenish
when teleporting to a site of Grace from
the map for a full list of patch notes
check out gamespot.com and I'll be sure
to drop a link below I'll also leave a
link to the OverWatch 2 season 2 patch
notes because that update is also live
the biggest change is the new tank
ramatra he can morph into two different
forms to change his tactics on the Fly
blizzard also changed up the battle pass
to make remotra easier to unlock at
level 45. season 2 will also see the
launch of competitive play at the end of
the season you will be rewarded limited
time titles based on your rank at the
end of the season you can only use those
titles in The Following season so the
titles you earned throughout season 2
will only be available during season
three Heroes that are not available for
competitive play will display a lock
icon in the hero Gallery improvements to
matchmaking and competitive UI have also
been made Let's Circle back to the
question I asked at the top of the video
switch and Call of Duty do you care is
it something you really wanted and do
you play a lot of Shooters on switch
because I for one just can't get down
with like trying to aim with the joy-con
it just doesn't work for me but that's
just me so let me know in the comments
what you think and I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
[Music]